[Music]
why don't you heal my [ __ ] leg
already dude
just touch him off [ __ ] a little bit
it'll feel better i promise touch on my
[ __ ]
okay two
one someone get some alcohol to davidson
oh no
other other than marvel and dc
there is a new comic book publisher no
that has started
oh it started yeah it started and it's
it's now taken off and it's created this
entirely new thing
where i'm bible man i love bible man
it's just the bible with pictures
oh [ __ ] this is actually kind of lit
dude i might actually read
would be so sick like a marvel in dc
well
it's a it's a competitor like a company
that makes these types of things whole
whole new universe of characters bible
man we got ezekiel
well at least like mainstream wise like
wild storm was one from back in the day
but this one's called rip averse
rip uppers make sure
it does it actually does but
what makes it unique
is that they pride themselves on being
the first non-woke comic universe what
so what's the difference yeah i don't
get it is marvel trying to be all like
dudes making out all that all day to be
progressive no but marvel and dc have
made lots of adjustments to make sure
that their characters are not offensive
to people so like robin's not sucking
off batman why they make shang chi then
shang chi is a chinese dude that his
superpowers [ __ ] kung fu that's
[ __ ] up yeah that's true
guess we're not working that hard
did you guys i mean maybe we haven't all
kept up with it but did you know
superman is no longer considered like
american
why
is he russian
he's an alien so the
the motto that it used to be when it was
superman was created was like truth
justice in the american way remember
that like saying they took the american
thing out that's why because it's too
like offensive too yeah i thought he was
an alien though didn't he fall from the
sky and like things that was krypton or
some [ __ ] yeah but like it's no longer
associated with anything american per se
yeah i mean but it was made in america
what about captain america are they
going to nerf him too that's not captain
america he's captain everybody
he's captain states so like here and
there like there's a bunch of
adjustments that they've made for like
certain characters but the thing is this
this comic universe is not anti-woke
it's not that it's just that they're
refusing to bend anything for the sake
of what they do exactly so what are some
of their characters racist man let's
make racist races
slash yeah how do you how can that be
almost like they're they're
well it's an over correction and it's
very offensive
their first race is character shanxi
they're just gonna bring him over to the
universe we're gonna break stereotypes
by doing kung fu
they don't have any characters that are
specifically any different than like
marvel or dc it's just like the same
[ __ ] but it's it's not gonna change
so so where did the uh that sentiment or
that understanding that they won't
uh bend to wokeness like where does that
come from officially speaking the author
and the creator's name is eric july he's
black he used to work at dc
and he didn't like that he dreamt of
being this comic artist worked his way
all the way up got there and now he has
to change all these things are like
shifting in ways that he's like that's
not the [ __ ] comic universe that's
now that's here in politics so he
doesn't want politics of the real world
to mix into fictional universes dude if
you're complaining about comic books and
how they're not like just and socially
accurate or whatever the [ __ ] you're a
[ __ ] loser
you're a [ __ ] nerd i will say this
though right the the only problem that i
have with that is that if he is truly a
comic book fan he's saying that comic
books shouldn't be a social political
thing that he's never read comic books
before right comic books have always
been about social political issues
captain america was during it was
propaganda it was war propaganda [ __ ] it
has always always always been like that
so if he is a comic book fan then he
should understand what this is about
every comic movie that we have seen
about a scene and we fall in love with
captain america what is that [ __ ] about
it's about patriotism right it was
daring against uh american russia all
this other type of stuff here has always
been in comic books since david what
about wolverine huh and storm huh it was
about body hair house disgusting
what about how jubilee was weak and
asian and her power was shooting
fireworks yeah
firecrackers
she actually didn't have any powers at
all she just had firecrackers in her
sleazy she just lit them before it
happened hold on stay right there hold
on it's coming out do his characters say
our favorite words though like [ __ ]
and [ __ ] or like i don't want travel i
don't know i don't see things i haven't
read an issue of it but
the company's actually doing extremely
well
oh they probably use that for their
script there sales are like they reached
2 million in sales and they just started
what i need to read this [ __ ] it kind of
like pertains to a lot of people now
because when you look at stuff on in
entertainment everything is so
pandering they're just pounding to
everybody right because they don't want
to hurt anybody's feelings like there
can't be something to push to the edge
even if it's happening like that in
comedy you can't go that far because
people are going to be offended but it's
like is that happening in marvel right
now we're like they're like i'm
non-binary man and then they're like
coming out it's superman the new
superman's bisexual right it is well
that's not so much the um uh the way
that i feel like it's manifesting and
like the marvel cinematic universe the
way that people are kind of like about i
think it is more on like the um
people don't understand uh why like sam
is the new captain america even though
he was already written like that in the
comics and they're kind of like why
don't we just have a regular captain
america why is it why does it have to be
this new black guy but it's like well it
was technically written like that but
this is the there's many arcs that
captain america can go down they're just
choosing the ones that are most kind of
like acceptable to like the societal
climate nowadays there's been a bisexual
superman since day one like stan lee
wrote that not dc that's dc
superman's bisexual the new one yeah the
son the son of superman that's what i
mean like the the original the original
comics that are written
um i'm talking about those they're
changing those like if if there's a new
superman comic that's written yeah if
it's made in 2020 i don't even count
that just [ __ ] yeah no that's what it
is that characters the issue that like
maybe a lot of like comic book nerds
feel is that they're [ __ ] with their
childhood right it's not so much like a
social political thing for them it's
more like i just remember this being
what i saw as a kid don't [ __ ] with this
right yeah so like like maybe what
bart's saying maybe the the thing is
like oh just make a new superman like
just leave by superman alone and then
have your bisexual with a th superman
we also don't really read the comics
like we see the movies that the comics
are you know that are based off the
comics so people because we're not
[ __ ] nerds right
because we get [ __ ] i try to get my ass
kicked yeah
like i'm sure in the comics there's a
lot of bigger differences that like
comic fans can see that we don't oh
we're scores the harry potter fans i
feel like yeah
we're fans we're not fanatics no yeah so
we know like generally what the universe
is about we know like these characters
but people did get upset about uh
finding out like after the seven harry
potter books were already out and the
story was done and then jk rowling being
like dumbledore is gay like way later on
so then prequels like fantastic beasts
now they like they play a part but same
thing like all seven books the whole
[ __ ] universe the story's already out
movies are like already more than half
made some of the authors like
yeah he actually is gay are people mad
about that because they thought it was
unnecessary or because they don't like
gay i think it's because it was just
random it seems like she did that as an
afterthought like what i want to [ __ ]
catch on this gay train so let me throw
that in there the gate train's popping
yeah it's gay trains going [ __ ] i
don't want to miss the gay train you
know and then so she's like you know
what we're lgbtq friendly too but don't
but i think she also got a lot of heat
for like trans like that's a different
thing
when she said a woman is a woman that
thing no she was basically talking about
how um
it's like there's it's a controversial
thing about giving uh
kids hormonal treatment for trans and
she was just talking about [ __ ] like
that and then like they're like you're
[ __ ] anti-trans [ __ ] what does ben
shapiro think about this huh that's what
i want to hear dude hey guys so what the
woman's a woman and a woman's a
woman love that guy dude he keeps
popping up on my [ __ ] feet i don't
understand why i keep saying i'm not
interested i'm not interested and he
just pops up as you're as you're
commenting i know i'm interacting to say
i'm not interested
oh you're supposed to oh you're not
supposed to write comments
how do i dislike this one i write it i
go dislike
dislike
just doing it wrong is that ben shapiro
and then the other guy uh he was the one
that went on dr phil to arg to have a
debate with a trans person mark walsh
have you heard of him no they keep
popping up on my feet what do you keep
on looking at yeah i keep on looking at
fat [ __ ] with fat asses i keep
getting this [ __ ] i'm like but you keep
accidentally picking the trans fat
[ __ ]
i'm like yo learn my algorithm please
like we are you know this is it
oh [ __ ]
he's having the same problem right now
hey that's a different video
[Laughter]
bring it back hey so if you guys were to
construct a superhero that was not
necessarily woke but we would vibe with
in today's world what would that be
doesn't it feel like it would take more
work to make sure the comic doesn't get
woke than if it just naturally started
feeling like it because you got to do
more yeah like what happened to just
having a good story
yeah like why does that have to have all
these freaking ways
because you put out a good story and
then somebody who's woke starts giving
you [ __ ] now you're [ __ ] dealing with
press in this other way because you're
trying to put out fires about how you're
actually not a terrible human being and
like that's also it almost feels more
difficult to be non-woke because you
have to make sure you don't seem woke
that means those comic books about to be
so racist and [ __ ] i'm like all right
cool down read that they go the opposite
way they just go full prejudice and [ __ ]
well the cool thing is it doesn't make
it that much different than a person or
like an entrepreneur seeing a space that
nothing exists and goes oh if i just
capitalize on this yeah it's good or
it's just another market so this guy's
like everybody's woke
ah
is there a list of like other
superheroes that he's created ching
chong man oh that's good
that's good what's his superpower huh
with noodles
the fastest delivery in the west the
noodles come out here
and i do it for cheaper than everybody
else
shoots duck sauce
he gives discounts to people he that
looks like him only
just a special price yeah the chinese
ikea for free
[Laughter]
i like him that's good
ching chong man
know
[Music]